there's a British hostage what's your
message to his family were one of huge
sympathy and understanding i think
everyone watching this program will be
thinking of them and praying for them
it's a desperately difficult situation
and what I would say is that when anyone
from Britain is taken hostage anywhere
in the world I immediately make sure
that the whole government comes together
the intelligence agencies are security
forces everything to ask what we can do
to help get that person back to help
their family to make sure the whole
system is working on their behalf but it
is a very difficult situation and of
course they have our complete sympathies
can you conceive of paying a ransom in
this case we don't pay ransoms we have a
very clear policy that we don't pay
ransoms to terrorists when they kidnap
our citizens and I at the g8 in Northern
Ireland got other world leaders to sign
up to this very important declaration
and it's important people stick to it
because I'm in no doubt that this
particular terrorist organization and
others around the world have made tens
of millions of dollars from people who
have paid rather sins and that money
goes into kidnapping more citizens from
European countries it goes into buying
weapons and arms and it also goes into
terrorist plots including plots against
our own country so this is the right
policy it is a difficult decision but
it's the right thing to do blaming our
European partners partly for this kid
now what I would say is Britain doesn't
pay for terrorists kidnaps on other
occasions payments have been made
sometimes I think governments have
turned a blind eye and I think that is
deeply regrettable as I say from the
intelligence and other information I've
seen there's no doubt this money helps
to fuel the crisis that we see in Iraq
and Syria we've seen a certain ramping
up of the rhetoric over the past couple
of days about is you can ISIL is this a
slow drum beat towards wall towards a
more concerted military action but what
it is is a recognition that this is an
organization that is a direct threat to
our country I mean if we think about
what happened in Afghanistan there we
had a Taliban regime that played host to
al-qaeda here in the heart of Iraq we've
actually got a terrorist organization
running a potential state with all the
resources and money that involves
look we have to take a long-term tough
intelligent patient view of this we're
going to have to squeeze it out of
existence it's going to take time we
start with the measures we take in our
own country to keep ourselves safe we
then work with partners to put the
pressure on this organization we're
helping to get arms to the Kurds we're
helping to get in Iraqi government whose
real responsibility it is to put the
squeeze on this organization and then we
work with allies and partners to ask
what more we can do use the phrase put
the squeeze is the aim to destroy is yes
no doubt the world would be a safer
place if we could squeeze this
organization out of existence what there
ought to be in Iraq is a democratic
Iraqi government that looks after all of
its people Sunnis Shia and Kurd what
they ought to be in Syria instead of a
conflict between a brutal dictator and
an opposition it is a democratic
government in Syria that can represent
all its people in the long term those
are the only answers it's a mixture of
the action we take and political
solutions on the ground but you cannot
deal with is without targeting their HQ
in Syria and how do you do that with
President Assad or without his tacit
support what as I say what we need is
that combination of working with those
on the ground who are fighting ISIL in
Iraq that is the Kurds and the Iraqi
government in Syria it's the official
Syrian opposition we need to work with
them obviously we also need to engage
with the regional partners and players
some sort of Western intervention that
goes over their heads and leaves them to
pick up the pieces that won't work any
engagement with President Assad I think
President sad is part of the problem not
part of the solution if you ask yourself
why has so-called Islamic state arisen I
would say it's got two main causes the
cause of a sad brutalizing his own
people without a stronger official
opposition to stand up for them and the
failure of an Iraqi government to govern
for all its people wherever in the world
you have broken States and conflict this
poisonous narrative of Islamist
extremism is able to get a foothold we
see that in Somalia we see it in
Afghanistan and now tragically we see it
in Iraq and Syria honest I detect
combat weariness following on from the
Syria votes following on from the great
debates about Iraq over the past 10 11
years is Britain combat weary by the way
I wouldn't accept that I'm an ayah as
Prime Minister I've been prepared to
take action where it's in our national
interest and where we can achieve our
goals and that's what we did in Libya
where we prevented a humanitarian
catastrophe where Gaddafi was going to
slaughter people in Benghazi leading
from the back here you're not wanting
together I think we do need to learn the
lessons of the past and I think one of
those lessons is that if you intervene
over the heads of local people then
you're less likely to be successful here
the question we should ask ourselves is
what more can we do to help those who
are fighting the so-called Islamic state
on the ground the Kurds and the Iraqi
government that is the approach we've
taken so far we should build on that
approach rather than seek to overturn it
one last quick domestic question are you
confident still about Scotland will be
paying more visits up there given the
tightening of the poles what obviously
it is a vitally important question for
the future are united kingdom and for
the future everyone living in Scotland
I've played my role in the campaign i'll
be making other interventions in that
campaign i was discussing it yesterday
and i hope people really focus now on
the risks there are of separation and
focus instead on the the bright future
we have I believe as part of the family
of Nations the United Kingdom Scott's in
my view have the chance the best of both
worlds more government from Edinburgh
more devolution to Edinburgh but while
being part of a bigger United Kingdom's
extrordinary doesn't last time the UK
hosted this Margaret Thatcher one of
your heroes was hosting it and to the
end of the Cold War and now we face the
worst relations with Russia in a
generation well you could look at it
another way which is it demonstrates the
importance of this NATO alliance it has
helped to keep the peace in Europe for
over 60 years and it is as relevant
today as it was when Margaret Thatcher
had that vital conference last time in
Britain that's why I was keen to bring
this conference again here to Britain as
NATO is not part of our past it's
actually vital to make sure we keep
peace and security in Europe and we
combat these threats like Islamist
extremism around the world thank you
very much Prime Minister